Et c'est parce que je les avaient écrites avec clarté,
j'ai pu alors
découvrir dans la foulée
que je pouvais intégrer ces principes dans des algorithmes,
et ces algorithmes seraient intégrés dans les ordinateurs,
et les ordinateurs prendraient des décisions avec moi ;
et donc prendre ces décisions parallèlement.
Et je pouvais comparer ces décisions avec mes propres décisions,
et ces décisions étaient en fait bien meilleures.
L'ordinateur pouvait prendre des décisions
en traitant bien plus de données,
en le faisait bien plus rapidement,
et sans l'interférence des émotions.
Cela a radicalement amélioré mes prises de décisions.
Huit ans après avoir créé Bridgewater,
j'ai subi mon plus grand échec,
et fait ma plus grande erreur.
C'était à la fin des années 70.
J'avais 34 ans.
Et j'avais calculé que les banques américaines
avaient prêté beaucoup trop d'argent aux pays émergents,
et que ces pays ne seraient pas en mesure de rembourser.
Et que nous aurions la pire crise de la dette
depuis la Grande Dépression.
Et de plus, une crise économique
et un énorme marché baissier.
C'était une vision controversée à l'époque.
D'aucuns pensaient que cette opinion était un peu folle.
Mais en août 1982,
le Mexique a été en défaut de paiement,
et plusieurs autres pays ont suivi.
Et on a eu la plus grande crise de la dette depuis la Grande Dépression.
Étant donné que je l'avais prévu,
j'avais témoigné devant le Congrès, et « Wall Street Week »
Juste pour vous donner une idée, j'ai un clip vidéo,
et vous me verrez dedans.
(Vidéo) M. le Président, M. Mitchell,
c'est un grand honneur et plaisir de me présenter devant vous
afin d'examiner ce qui ne va pas avec notre économie.
Une l'économie anémique...
au bord de l'échec.
Il a été fait mention de vous dans un article.
Je cite : « Je peux dire cela avec une certitude absolue car
je sais comment le marché fonctionne. »
Ray Dalio : « En toute certitude,
si vous regardez la base de liquidités
dans les entreprises et dans le monde,
ce niveau est si faible qu'il n'y aura pas de retour à une ère de stagflation. »
Là je me dis : « Quel abruti arrogant ! »
(Rires)
J'étais si arrogant, et j'avais tort.
En fait, lors de la crise de la dette,
le marché boursier et l'économie étaient en hausse,
et j'ai perdu tellement d'argent, le mien et celui de mes clients,
que j'ai dû presque fermer boutique,
la quasi totalité des employés sont partis.
Nous étions comme une grande famille.
J'avais le cœur brisé.
Et j'ai perdu tellement d'argent
que j'ai dû emprunter 4 000 dollars à mon père
pour payer les factures de mon foyer.
Une des expériences les plus douloureuses de ma vie...
qui va, en fait, s'avérer être une bénédiction,
parce qu'elle a changé mon attitude envers la prise de décision.
Plutôt que de penser : « J'ai raison ! »,
j'ai commencé à me demander :
« Comment savoir si j'ai raison ? »
J'ai gagné l'humilité dont j'avais besoin
en vue d'équilibrer mon audace.
Cherchant les plus brillants de ceux qui avaient un avis opposé au mien,
afin de comprendre leur point de vue,
et les pousser à tester le mien.
Je voulais créer une méritocratie liée aux idées.
A vrai dire,
pas une autocratie dans laquelle je dirige et les autres suivent,
ni une démocratie où tous les points de vue ont la même valeur,
mais une méritocratie liée aux idées, où les meilleures idées l'emportent.
Pour cela, Il fallait une franchise radicale,
et transparence radicale.
Par franchise radicale et transparence radicale,
j'entends que nous devons dire ce que nous pensons vraiment,
et la nécessité de la transparence.
Nous avons donc enregistré presque toutes les conversations,
rendues accessibles à tous,
on ne pouvait faire autrement,
si on voulait garantir une méritocratie liée aux idées.
Afin d'avoir une telle méritocratie,
on doit laisser tout le monde s'exprimer librement.
Comme exemple,
voici un email de Jim Haskel,
quelqu'un qui travaille pour moi,
et accessible à tous au sein de l'entreprise.
« Ray, tu mérites un 07/20
pour ta performance lors de la réunion...
Yu n'étais pas bien préparé du tout,
car il est impossible d'être aussi désorganisé... »
Génial ! Non ?
(Rires)
C'est formidable,
parce que, tout d'abord, j'avais besoin d'un tel feedback.
J'ai besoin de feedback similaires.
Et c'est génial car si je ne laisse pas Jim,
et des gens comme Jim,
exprimer leur point de vue,
notre relation ne saurait être la même.
Et si cela n'était pas accessible, en toute transparence,
nous n'aurions pas eu une méritocratie des idées.
Donc depuis 25 ans, c'est ainsi que nous avons fonctionné.
Nous avons fonctionné avec cette transparence radicale,
et puis nous avons collecté ces principes,
venant dans une large mesure de nos erreurs,
et puis nous avons intégré ces principes dans des algorithmes.
Et puis ces algorithmes permettent...
nous suivons les algorithmes,
en parallèle avec nos réflexions.
C'est ainsi que nous avons géré nos activités d'investissement,
et c'est ainsi que nous traitons la gestion du personnel.
Afin de vous donner une idée du processus,
j'aimerais vous emmener à une réunion
et vous présenter un outil nommé le « Dot Collector »
nous aidant dans ce sens.
Une semaine après les élections américaines,
notre équipe de recherche a tenu une réunion
sur les répercussions de l'élection de Trump sur l'économie américaine.
Bien sûr, il y a eu des opinions divergentes sur la question,
et sur la manière d'aborder la discussion.
« Dot Collector » recueille ces opinions.
Il a une liste avec des dizaines d'attributs,
Quand on a une opinion sur une idée émise par l'autre,
il est facile de partager une évaluation.
On note tout simplement l'attribut, et on donne une note de 1 à 10.
Par exemple, au début de la réunion,
une chercheuse nommée Jen m'a donné une note de trois...
autrement dit, une note médiocre.
(Rires)
pour manque d'équilibre entre ouverture d'esprit et affirmation de soi.
Au cours de la réunion,
voici le résultat des évaluations de Jen.
Les autres avaient des opinions divergentes.
C'est normal.
Nous avons tous des opinions différentes.
Et qui sait qui a raison?
Alors qu'en est-il de ma performance?
Pour certains je m'étais pas mal débrouillé,
et pour d'autres, mal...
Pour chaque opinion,
on peut découvrir la réflexion derrière les notes.
Voilà ce que Jen et Larry ont dit.
Notez que chacun peut exprimer sa pensée,
et son esprit critique,
quel que soit le poste dans l'entreprise.
Jen, 24 ans, récemment diplômée,
peut me dire, au PDG, que j'appréhende mal la situation.
Cet outil aide les gens à exprimer leur opinion,
et aussi à s'en détacher,
et voir les choses avec une autre perspective.
Quand Jen et d’autres dirigent leur attention de leur opinion
vers une vision plus globale,
un changement d'optique en résulte.
Chacun réalise que son avis n'est qu’un avis parmi d’autres,
et naturellement ils commencent à se demander :
« Comment savoir si mon avis est juste ? »
C'est comme passer d'une vision en une seule dimension
à une vision multidimensionnelle,
réorientant une conversation argumentative
vers des critères objectifs qui ciblent les meilleurs avis.
Derrière le « Dot Collector », il y a un ordinateur qui surveille,
qui observe tout ce que ces personnes pensent
et qui relie le tout avec leur manière de penser.
Et sur cette base, il les conseille en retour.
Ensuite, il tire les données de toutes les réunions
afin de créer un portrait pointilliste des personnes,
et leur façon de penser.
Tout ça guidé par des algorithmes.
Connaitre les gens permet une meilleure adéquation des compétences et des emplois.
Par exemple,
un penseur créatif mais peu fiable
peut être compatible avec quelqu'un de fiable mais pas créatif.
Connaitre les gens permet aussi de décider
quelles responsabilités leur confier,
et d'évaluer nos décisions en fonction du mérite de ces personnes.
En fonction de leur crédibilité.
Voici l'exemple d’un vote
où la majorité avait une certaine opinion,
mais suite à l'évaluation des opinions basée sur le mérite,
le résultat a totalement changé.
Ce processus nous permet de prendre des décisions
basées non sur la démocratie, ou l’autocratie,
mais basées sur des algorithmes
qui prennent en considération la crédibilité.
Oui, on fait vraiment ça.
(Rires)
Nous le faisons parce que cela élimine
ce qui constitue pour moi l'une des plus grandes tragédies de l'humanité,
c’est-à-dire que dans notre arrogance,
naïvement, nous chérissons des opinions erronées,
et leur donnons suite,
et nous ne les exprimons pas afin de pouvoir les tester.
Et c’est une tragédie.
Faire cela, c'est nous élever au-dessus de nos propres opinions,
afin de voir enfin le monde au travers des yeux des autres,
et de le voir de manière collective.
Une prise de décision collective est bien plus efficace qu'une décision individuelle
si tout est bien fait.
Elle a été la recette secrète de notre succès.
Gagnant plus d'argent pour nos clients
que les autres fonds d'investissement spéculatif,
réalisant des bénéfices 23 années sur les 26 dernières années.
Alors quel est le problème avec le fait d'être totalement sincères
d'être radicalement transparents entre nous ?
On dit qu'il y a un côté affectif difficile à gérer.
Les critiques disent que c'est la formule pour un environnement de travail brutal.
Les neuroscientifiques disent que c'est lié au pré-câblage de nos cerveaux.
Il y a une part de notre cerveau qui veut bien reconnaître nos erreurs
et faire face à nos faiblesses afin de nous améliorer la prochaine fois.
On me dit que c'est le cortex préfrontal.
Ensuite il y a une partie de notre cerveau
qui voit tout ça comme des attaques.
On me dit que c'est l'amygdale.
Autrement dit, à l’intérieur de vous, il y a deux « vous » :
il y a un « vous » émotionnel
et il y a un « vous » intellectuel,
et ils sont souvent en désaccord,
et ils travaillent souvent contre vous.
Par expérience, nous savons que nous pouvons gagner cette bataille.
Nous la gagnons en tant que groupe.
Cela prend environ 18 mois en général
pour découvrir que la plupart des gens préfèrent fonctionner ainsi,
avec cette transparence radicale,
plutôt que de travailler dans un environnement opaque.
On ne fait pas de politique, il n'y a pas de brutalité celle...
vous savez, tout ce qui est caché, en coulisses...
Il y a une méritocratie des idées, et on s'exprime librement.
Une expérience magnifique !
Résultant en un travail plus efficace,
et des relations privilégiées.
Ce n'est pas le cas pour tous.
Pour 25 ou 30% de la population,
cela ne fonctionne pas.
Et d'ailleurs, quand je dis
transparence radicale,
je veux pas dire la transparence à propos de tout.
Je veux dire, vous n'avez pas à dire à quelqu'un que sa calvitie est visible,
ou que son bébé est moche.
Donc, ceci s'applique seulement...
(Rires)
aux choses importantes.
Alors...
(Rires)
Alors quand vous quitterez cette salle,
il serait bien de prêter attention à vos conversations.
Imaginez si vous saviez ce que l'autre pense vraiment,
et imaginez si vous saviez vraiment qui ils sont...
Et imaginez s'ils savaient vraiment ce que vous pensez,
et qui vous êtes vraiment.
Cela clarifierait certainement une foule de choses,
et rendrait votre échange beaucoup plus fluide.
Je pense que cela améliorerait vos relations.
Maintenant imaginez que vous avez accès à des algorithmes
qui peuvent vous aider à rassembler toutes ces informations,
et même vous aider à prendre des décisions basées sur la méritocratie liée aux idées.
Ce genre de transparence radicale arrive à grands pas,
et va avoir un impact sur votre vie.
Et à mon avis,
ça sera merveilleux.
J’espère que cela sera aussi merveilleux pour vous,
qu'il le fut pour moi.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)